[Música]
con nuestro primer invitado el día vamos
a hablar de la polémica propuesta de
reformar el sistema de pensiones del
gobierno francés se espera que cerca de
un millón de personas salgan hoy a las
calles para rechazar entre otras cosas
que esta edad de jubilación aumente de
62 a 64 años saludamos entonces a
nuestro invitado Gaspar estrales
politólogo de la Universidad sansport de
París Gracias Gaspar por estar con
nosotros en directo América de Francia
24 y analicemos toda esta polémica de
reforma pensional que quiere impulsar y
que quiere llevar a cabo por supuesto el
gobierno de presidente franceses Emanuel
macron esto dice para garantizar dentro
de poco un déficit fiscal en el país
dentro de todo este sistema pensional y
que no se derrumbe
Así es eso es el objeto de esta
propuesta al menos ese es el discurso de
El jefe del ejecutivo francés lo que
está claro según las encuestas es que
esta propuesta de reforma de pensiones
es mal vista por una mayor parte de la
opinión pública el día de hoy no menos
de tres encuestas Fueron publicadas por
diferentes institutos y todos van en la
misma dirección
más de la mitad de los franceses Están
en contra de esta reforma ahora bien hay
que ver cuál será pues la consecuencia
política de las manifestaciones del día
de hoy y cómo pues se va a a desarrollar
esta correlación de fuerzas entre por un
lado los sindicatos y por el otro el
gobierno lo conversábamos precisamente
antes con nuestra cronista de revista de
prensa Rosa Pérez más deu con el medio
media Park también que tenía un artículo
de opinión diciendo que ve cierta
dificultad también algunos analistas que
este movimiento masivo que podemos ver
el día de hoy puede ser continúe no más
allá y realmente sea una piedra de
tranca para que el presidente impulse
esta reforma pensional además que fácil
tiene macron para poder instaurarlo no
claro eso siempre es un poco la lógica
que que existe en Francia cuando hay
este tipo de movimientos sociales de los
gobiernos de manera general apuestan a
una suerte de cansancio del movimiento
social una radicalización Por ende
también más violencia y Desde esa
perspectiva pues obtener que esta
violencia se traduzca en una reducción
del apoyo de la opinión pública a los
manifestantes sin embargo también hay
precedentes como el 95 cuando hubo
también una gran huelga contra en un
proceso de reforma de las pensiones en
la cual esta estrategia pues no no
funcionó y el gobierno tuvo que dar
marcha atrás yo creo que lo que hay que
estar pendientes el día de hoy y en los
días que que vienen es saber cómo va a
reaccionar la opinión pública y ver si
los manifestantes van a ver su posición
reforzada o no Gaspar analicemos un poco
las claves de lo que es este sistema
pensional en Francia uno de los más
generosos sin duda de toda la Unión
Europea instaurado entonces a finales de
la Segunda Guerra Mundial uno también de
los puntos claves que la gente rechaza
es esta eliminación a los sistemas
preferenciales que progresivamente se
van a ir quitando sobre todo a los
empleados de las compañías públicas de
energía y de transportes no
Así es ese es uno de los objetos
principales de esta reforma según
digamos la expresión gubernamental O sea
la la digamos la el la estrategia y
comunicación de gobierno se trataría de
armonizar
los sistemas diferentes sistemas de
pensiones que existen en Francia para
generar un un mismo sistema y Por ende
generar economías Pero por otro lado lo
que alegan los trabajadores de esas
empresas es que sus condiciones de
trabajo sus empleos digamos tienen una
serie de especificidades que
justifican la existencia de estos
regímenes preferenciales y todo el el
debate político el debate mediático que
que va a llevarse a cabo en las próximas
días horas y semanas va a llevarse a
cabo alrededor de estas dos narrativas
entre por un lado una narrativa
gubernamental que dice vamos a defender
el fin de los privilegios y por el otro
una voluntad de reivindicar el trabajo y
las especificidades de este de estos
trabajos Gaspar hablemos de los hechos
ese fundamental realmente es necesario
esta reforma al sistema pensional en
Francia debido al envejecimiento de la
población con el aumento de la esperanza
de vida realmente Esto sí puede tener
más adelante un desequilibrio en todo el
sistema
Bueno yo no soy especialista en en
finanzas públicas lo que sí puedo
constatar es que el la edad de
jubilación en Francia Comparado a sus
pares europeos es inferior es decir en
Francia las personas se jubilan
digamos con mayor antelación que por
ejemplo en Alemania en España o en
Italia lo que Pero por otro lado lo que
está claro es que las cifras Al menos
que da el consejo de orientación de
jubilaciones look es un el organismo un
poco externo a cargo de fiscalizar la
Cuenta pública pues ha apuntado un un
déficit de el sistema de de pensiones y
ha propuesto una serie de medidas sin
embargo estas medidas no son los que
fueran digamos incorporadas por el
gobierno en su propuesta y de hecho el
gobierno ha cambiado varias veces de
propuesta para cambiar
el sistema de jubilación Entonces yo
creo que existe un debate sobre cómo
puede llevarse a cabo esta reforma creo
que la la en sí el la idea de cambiar el
régimen de de pensiones No no es tanto
objeto de debate sino la manera como se
va como se va a llevar a cabo y ahí es
donde reside el debate que existe hoy
entre los sindicatos y el gobierno
hablemos precisamente Gaspar de de ese
debate no existe algún tipo de
contrapropuesta por parte de los
sindicatos laborales los principales del
país a este plan de Reforma pensional
planteado por el gobierno del presidente
de Manuel macron o por el contrario
simplemente quieren que se quede acto
como está actualmente
Bueno yo creo que por un lado sí quieren
que el sistema en particular en las
empresas públicas de Electricidad bueno
de energía de manera más general y de
transportes
mantengan su especificidad sin embargo
lo que sí está planteado de Parte de
algunos organismos sindicales y de
miembros de la oposición es que se tome
en cuenta en una eventual reforma de
pensiones el tema de la penibilidad de
los empleos y el hecho que muchas
personas precarias o que ocupan empleos
mal remunerados empiezan a trabajar muy
tempranamente en el en estas empresas y
Por ende en la edad de jubilación
tendría que tomar cuenta de esta
penibilidad desde ese punto de vista hay
todo un debate hoy en el congreso donde
se están discutiendo una serie de
reformas a la a la propuesta de El
gubernamental para poder incorporar ese
tema de la penibilidad de los empleos en
una eventual reforma de las pensiones